So, last lecture Percy covered some of
the, you know, underlying mechanics,
let's call it, of parallelism.
Today I'm going to do my favorite thing
of talk about all sorts of sort of
things you can know, like knowledge
details and trivia about
how modern parallelism for language
model training works.
Um
and what we're going to try to do is
really get to grips with the many, many
complexities that are involved when you
are having to train huge models on huge
clusters.
Um it's going to turn out that there are
many different parallelization
strategies that you can use at once. Um
at the end we will get to a slide where
I say 4D parallelism because there's
four different things they can do at
once, actually even more that I'll talk
about. Um and it turns out that to
parallelize at the largest scale, you'll
need to use kind of all of them or most
of them. Um and we'll sort of discuss
why. Um part of your assignment will be
figuring out um given a particular sort
of network topology and a particular
model, what is the optimal
parallelization strategy for that.
And then finally, I'll walk through some
examples of recent large-scale training
runs with details that are published and
kind of show you this stuff in action.
Okay. So, the very first part I'll I'll
go through somewhat quickly. It's
partially a review of basic collectives,
basic networking primitives, right? Um
but the reason why we need all of this
parallelism stuff is because there's
going to be two bottlenecks that will
solve by going to multiple machines and
multiple GPUs. So, one of it is compute.
We need more compute than we can bring
to bear on a single chip, and the way we
solve that is just to have many, many
machines and link them up together,
right? The fastest supercomputers in the
world have like exaflops of compute,
whereas, you know, um a single GPU is is
nowhere near that number.
Um the other reason why we need to
continue to scale in parallel is because
of memory, right? Models are big, we
can't fit them all into one GPU, so we
need to shard them into smaller pieces
somehow.
Um so this is going to lead to
complexities of having many GPUs across
many different machines. And an
important conceptual object that we will
deal with throughout um our lecture
today is the difference between
intra-node parallelism where your
connections are very fast, and so you
can do things that are very
communication expensive, and you're
going to have slower inter-node com-
communication. And because these are
slow, we will have to use sort of a
processes that that respect the
communication constraints of our channel
more, right? So we're going to have to
do both of those.
And remember, you know, all of the
things that we will do today, um we're
not actually going to be, you know,
sending packets or anything like that.
We're going to be dealing with this at
the level of uh collective communication
primitives, right? So um whenever we do
accounting for, you know, how much
communication is done, I might say,
"Okay, you know, we're going to have to
do a do a all reduce, or we're going to
have to do a all gather to implement
some of these operations." So um
in order to implement some of these
efficiently, um you're going to have to
go all the way to the hardware level.
But our discussion today is going to be
algorithmic, and so all of the
networking primitives I'll talk about is
going to be at this level of a of a
collective.
And remember, Percy talked about this,
but this is important for um very
important for one part of the talk,
which is going to be that the
equivalence between all reduce and uh
reduce scatter plus all gather, right?
So um there's going to be one algorithm
where on one hand you do a all reduce,
and on the other hand you do, you know,
two of these different steps. And the
fact that these two have the same sort
of cost in some sense um
means that, you know, we can do the
algorithm on the right for free. We'll
we'll see that again later. This is just
a a quick refresher just to make sure
you remember uh what Percy said.
Okay, so that's, you know, it for for
the really basic review. Um the other
thing I want to touch on briefly before
we get into the algorithms, which are
going to be kind of hardware and
substrate agnostic, is the difference
Oh, sorry. Yes.
>> So,
is there any particular reason why we
are saying that all the gradients are
going to be reduced scatter and
>> Okay, the the question was is there any
reason why I'm talking about this
specifically? We will
>> You can also say that all the gradients
is equal to reduce the cost
>> Yes, yes, there are other
decompositions. This one in particular
will be useful for AI algorithm, which
is why I'm emphasizing this particular
decomposition. That's right. There
there's others that you could do, of
course. Yes.
Okay. Um so, the other thing I will talk
about before I start,
most of our discussion today will be
hardware agnostic. Like for the most
part, once you understand the basic
concepts, you'll be able to apply it to
any hardware substrate. Um but I do want
to sort of briefly before we start just
talk about the low-level hardware stack,
both because it's kind of interesting,
um but also because I think it leads to
different sort of uh parallelization
strategies across different um model
training companies.
So, remember the TPU, right? TPU is
Google's accelerator. Um and I mentioned
during the GPU lecture, a TPU is kind of
like a lightweight GPU, but what's
different is the networking. So, how is
the networking different? Well,
in sort of one slide, um the the TPU
network is what's called a toroidal
mesh, right? So, you can think about a
grid and then sort of like allowing the
ends of the grid to communicate with
each other. It's a little bit more
complicated. It's a 3D uh picture, um
which, you know, Marcel, you have the
visualization, right? Can you can you
post that in the in the uh the lecture
channel? Yeah. So, there's like a fun
web visualization that you can look at
that like visualizes the toroidal mesh
in 3D, which is very cool. But your your
mental model, I think, can roughly be
this picture. You can forget the the
more complex one. All the chips are
networked kind of to neighbors, and the
neighbors wrap around, right? So, what
does this let you do? This lets you have
a very simple networking topology that
can be indefinitely scaled up very
simply, right? You're the number of
neighbors you have is kind of the the no
matter how large your your uh network
gets. Um in contrast, the GPU networking
philosophy is very different. It's
really much more of a all-to-all
philosophy. And the way that it's
networked is it's kind of like a tree.
Um it's often called a fat tree. You
have, you know, your GPUs connected very
very quickly at the lowest layers, and
then you have groups of GPUs that are
connected in a pod, and then the pods
might have sort of spine switches that
allow them to communicate to each other.
And this means that as the number of
nodes grows, you know, kind of the tree
gets bigger and bigger, your
communication costs is going to get
higher or your communication sort of
topology will get more complicated
because you're sort of connecting all of
these all-to-all as you go.
Now,
this difference in philosophy means that
if you're communicating only to
neighbors, TPUs are great. They're
cost-effective um and you can make each
connection sort of more beefy, right?
With the same power consumption. But if
you're connecting in very random ways,
like very stochastic, unpredictable
ways, then this GPU networking will be
more flexible, right? So, there's this
very different design philosophy um that
you see between TPUs and GPUs, and I'll
try to mention um where this shows up as
we go through uh the parallelism
lecture.
Um and I posted this into the lecture
chat um last lecture, you know, because
someone asked, you know, what's the
difference between these two and so on,
right? But um just to back up my point,
you know, Bill Dally and Jeff Dean were
sort of talking about the different sort
of hardware and like what are what
they're good for, right? Um you know,
GPUs are good for things like mixture of
experts, where the communication is much
less clear because tokens route to
different experts. Um TPUs are great if
you have this dense model that you're
doing sort of um very predictable
partitions of. I'll talk about that um
in a in a idea called tensor parallelism
uh later in this lecture. And so, these
hardware things are are good for
different workloads, and this was kind
of where I was going to leave it for the
lecture until this morning, when Google
decided that they were going to announce
deep TPU AI and T this morning. Um and
then I looked at this as I was, you
know, preparing my lecture and I said,
"Oh my god, PPU AI, that's a tree
topology. They've like switched to like
a much more all-to-all connection." Um,
and you know, if you think about it, it
makes sense. Um,
you know, modern-day language models are
MOEs, and if you're going to serve a
MOE, you're going to have all sorts of
bandwidth just flying around as you
route tokens to different experts. You
probably do want much more of a
all-to-all
um
connectivity where, you know, at
inference time these communications are
real bottlenecks. You want to kind of
deal with them.
Um,
and even at sort of training time, the
TPU 8T, which is their training chip,
you know, it's sort of the the
cross-rack connectivity like looks a lot
more like a GPU. Like there's much more
like a all-to-all style uh switch uh
that's being built out called the the
Virgo network. That's a higher-level
uh networking stack.
So, I think there's kind of really
interesting things happening. It's a
little bit of a conversion evolution um
across both TPUs and GPUs where really
the workloads are kind of defining the
network that we need to have.
Okay. And then the final thing about
hardware, you know, I just love talking
about kind of the what's happening in
the Chinese AI scene, um is kind of this
idea of, you know, I think in the GPU
lecture someone asked, "If SRAM is so
good, why don't you just all use SRAM?
Like only SRAM chip." And that's Groq,
right? It works really well. Now, some
of you might be thinking, you know, if
all-to-all connectivity is good, why
don't you just connect everything and
connect them with really fast fiber
optic chips, right? Um, and then you
would kind of get the Huawei Ascend 910,
right? Um, so if you look at the specs
of the Huawei Ascend, um it's actually
really interesting because each chip is
a lot worse than a H200. Like it's a lot
slower at matmuls, you know, it's, you
know, kind of slower in many ways, but
then, you know, if you're willing to
dedicate kind of a giant rack of sort of
fiber optic switches to connect a much
larger number of chips, like in their
case 384
uh in a big rack, um then maybe you can
kind of deal with the fact that each
chip is slower by just connecting a
much, much larger number of these guys,
right?
Um
And then so I think what this shows us
is a really interesting trade-off
because once you look at this
architecture, you realize the power
consumption of this thing is insanely
high. It's four times that of the
equivalent Nvidia system.
And so it's something like, well, you
know, if you're willing to pay the power
cost, you can solve a lot of, you know,
kind of communication problems brute
force and you can scale out much more
aggressively to 300 chips,
but you're paying a power cost, right?
Similar to that SRAM story of if you
want to design a hardware that is
efficient to use both power and
manufacturing-wise, you end up in a
certain place. If you want to brute
force things, you end up in a very
different place, right? So, this is this
is I think just a very interesting
place to learn from about sort of these
hardware design trade-offs.
Okay, good. Um so now, you know, just to
put this all together, the first thing
you should think about is the new unit
of compute is not the GPU, it's the
entire data center. And we want to have
several things. We want to be able to
control the amount of memory we use. We
want to be able to control the amount of
compute that we can bring to bear. And
we want all of these to kind of be
lossless, right? We want to use all of
the resources that we have. Um
And then, you know, we're going to, you
know, talk about the algorithms that
will enable this through all these like
communication primitives components.
Okay.
Good.
So now, the second part of this lecture
is going to be the bulk of the content.
And these are kind of the algorithms
that we will use to
parallelize language models.
And there's going to be a couple
different important ideas.
Um
Actually, these should probably maybe
even be grouped. You know, data parallel
is one set of ideas for essentially
taking your data that that going to
train on and distributing them across
GPUs. So, the data is the ones that move
around. Um and then model parallelism,
you're going to chop up different parts
of the model and split them around. Um
turns out that the boundary between
these two is a little leaky because one
of the algorithms here will actually cut
parameters up too. But, we will see kind
of why I've put all these algorithms
into these different bins, right? Um and
conceptually, we're trying to both scale
out compute and memory, and that's why
we will need a whole bunch of these
different um tricks.
Cool.
All right. So, data parallelism, I think
is the easiest to understand. It is
conceptually very simple, and I think
it's the, you know, standard way that
you would try to parallelize an
algorithm like uh LM training.
So, forget that we're doing Adam. We're
going to do just naive uh SGD for the
moment. Um and we have a capital B
back-sized batch, right? So, each update
step, I'm going to take capital B
elements, and I'm going to sum up the
gradients, and I'll take my update,
right? So, the most naive form of
parallelism that one can do for this is
to take my batch, B. I can cut it up
across M machines. If they're divisible,
each machine will get a smaller, you
know, B over M sized batch. And then,
what I'm going to do is each machine
computes gradients, and then I will
synchronize all the gradients um to get
my, you know, sum.
Okay, great. So, compute scaling-wise,
you know, this is perfect as long as
there's enough examples per GPU, we're
good. Communications overhead, how much
do we have to talk to each other? Well,
every batch, we have to basically
communicate two times the number of
parameters, right? Because what I have
to do um is I have to basically
communicate my gradients for uh back and
forth.
Okay. And then, for memory scaling,
there's absolutely none. Every GPU has
the same copies of the models. You need
to have the same sized activations. So,
you don't save any memory at all in this
scheme.
Um
So, now, what is the problem? Clearly,
we've addressed compute to to extent,
but we have not addressed the memory at
all. So, let's take a look at kind of
this memory, you know, problem and just
do a little bit of accounting.
Um initially, it might seem that the
memory situation is bad, but it turns
out our memory situation is actually
just terrible. Um and the reason why the
memory situation is terrible is if you
just kind of do some parameter
accounting, right? Like it it just turns
out you need to store a lot of stuff,
right? And not only do we need to store
a lot of stuff, it's actually more than
the parameters that we need to store.
So, um roughly the rule of thumb, it
depends on your precision, but the rule
of thumb you might say is that we need
something like five copies of weights um
and 16 bytes per parameter to store a
model. Um so, you know, we will need to
of course store our model parameters. We
need a place to put our gradients,
right? You know, it's kind of
accumulator before we put them into the
model parameters. So, we need to store
those uh guys.
Um but actually, you need to maybe store
more stuff. Um you might need to have
like a higher precision accumulator that
you accumulate into an SGD. This might
be temporary, but you might need this.
Um and if you're doing Adam, and this is
really where the bad stuff comes in, um
you're going to need to track both the
first and second moments of your
gradients, and you need to track them
over time, right? So, you need two of
these, and unfortunately, um you might
need to store them in high precision
depending on your stability
characteristics, and these might be
quite expensive, right? Um and we
generally call these things optimizer
state, right? Like the the thing that
you're accumulating into, the first
moment, the second moment, right? And
these are actually quite expensive. If
you look at the accounting, this is most
of the cost memory-wise of doing an SGD
update.
Um and so, I think one of the really,
you know, elegant and nice, you know,
things that you can do in this space is
to start cutting up the amount of memory
you need um and distributing them across
the accelerators, but doing so in this
structured way that gets you these gains
for basically free.
So, as I kind of said in the last slide,
the optimizer state is most of your
memory. So, here, you know, the
optimizer state is green, that's most of
your memory. Um orange is your
gradients, and uh blue is your
parameters. And notice how parameters
and gradients are the same size, and
your state is bigger, right? Um if you
do naive data parallel, you're just
going to replicate all of these this
state across the GPUs. And this is not
so good, right? Because you've, in some
sense, consumed way more memory than you
need, and your memory consumption is
linear with your number of accelerators.
Not so good, right? Um what we can do
instead is perhaps we can shard the
optimizer state onto different GPUs, and
this would be a big savings. If we shard
different other parts of, you know, what
we need to track, that would be also big
savings. Like maybe we can also shard
the gradients into different GPUs, or in
the extreme, maybe we can shard
everything into different accelerators.
And then you can see that, you know, the
the implied memory gains on the very
right would be quite dramatic as we go
all the way down from 120 to 1.9.
Now, um the main thing that we will sort
of study now is what is the cost of
doing this, right? You might imagine
there's no free lunch, you know,
baseline is going to be the fastest, and
as we go downwards to here, we're going
to have to pay a big communication cost
in order to achieve these memory
savings. I think the remarkable thing is
going to be that a lot of this will be
free.
Um but I'm going to walk through this
step by step. Um so, let's start with um
what people call zero stage one. Um so,
there's going to be three stages
corresponding to each of these steps.
And so, stage one is going to be the
simplest. The only thing I will shard is
my optimizer state, and I will shard it
across the GPUs, okay? Um everyone is
going to have both the parameters and
the gradients.
Um and so, what you can think of is each
worker is going to be responsible for
updating one slice of the parameters.
So, if I'm GPU number zero, my
responsibility is updating this very
first slice over here, um and I'm not
responsible for any of the other
updates.
So, how would it work, right? So, what
we're going to do is everyone computes
everyone has a different data item,
right? So, they're going to compute a
full gradient on their data item. That's
the first step. Now, I'm going to take
the gradient I computed, and I'm going
to reduce scatter the gradients onto all
the other machines because everyone else
needs my gradients, right? But, they
don't need all the gradients. They only
need the gradients associated with their
update, right? So, every worker is going
to get, you know, from me my gradient,
but their part of the parameter space,
right? So, this is going to be
equivalent to a number of parameters
communication cost because I'm sending
my gradient, but I'm cutting it up and
sending it into each GPU.
Now, each machine is going to be able to
now do their update. They have their
parameters, they have their gradients
that they got from everybody else, and
they have their own state that they've
tracked, right? And now, the parameters
have been updated, and now I'm going to
all gather them back, right? I was
responsible for, let's say, like 1/4 of
the parameters. So, those updated
parameters I'm going to send back to
everybody else, right? So, this is a
uh
all gather, right? So, this is where the
the equivalence is kind of useful. How
many sort of operations did I do? Well,
in the naive data parallel case, you
know, what I had to do was I had to do
one all reduce, right? I had to sort of
exchange all the gradients of everybody,
um and then do the updates, right? So,
the communication cost is two times the
parameters. Now, in zero stage one, you
know, I did two operations. One was a
reduce scatter to send the gradients
out, and then a all gather to collect
the updated parameters. But, we already
said a reduce scatter and a all gather
is equivalent to an all reduce. So, zero
stage one is going to have the exact
same sort of communication
characteristics as naive DDP, right? So,
this was free. Free memory savings.
Wonderful, right? And we look at the
memory, you know, we've basically taken
the parameters and anything that's not
optimizer state, I've divided by NGPUs,
right? Wonderful, wonderful, wonderful.
Now, can we do more? Well, zero stage
two is now going to say I'm going to
split the gradients up, and then I'm
going to um
you know, shard that as well.
Now, this is going to be trickier
because before I was relying on the fact
that I can compute the entire gradient.
Now, I can't even materialize the whole
gradient. So, what do I do?
Um well, this turns out to just be kind
of a systems trick. You know, as I sweep
backwards through my network, you know,
I don't need to compute the full
gradient. I can send out the gradients
to the associated workers um
as I kind of go. So, the key step here
is now instead of materializing the
gradient vector all at once, I'm going
to walk backwards through the compute
graph. And after computing a layer's
gradients, I'm going to immediately just
reduce that to send that to the right
worker, right? And once gradients aren't
needed in the backwards graph, just
immediately free it, right? So, you're
kind of now incrementally computing and
sending gradients as you go. And as you
can see, you know, doing it
incrementally or doing it all at once,
same thing, right? So, it doesn't really
make a difference. So, now you can at
the end, once again, all gather the
parameters.
I've sharded the gradients in some sense
without incurring any additional costs,
right?
Okay. So, the last and the most hairy
thing, and this always, you know, when I
first learned about this seemed like
total magic, is, you know, we've gotten
something for free so far. So, let's
keep pushing it. I'm going to shard the
parameters as well um all the way across
all the states. Um and so, we're going
to use the same kind of idea that we
used in zero stage two. And the idea,
remember, was I'm going to do things
incrementally, right? Um and so, what
I'm going to do is I'm going to send and
sort of receive parameters on demand
while stepping through the compute
graph. And this is really tricky because
each GPU only sees a slice of both the
parameters, gradients, and optimizer
states at any one time, right?
Um and this is zero stage three, also
known as FSDP, if you've ever paralyzed,
you know, anything in a torch library,
you've probably dealt with this before.
Um, so, the way that it works under the
hood, um, is what you're going to do is
you're going to do two all gathers and
one reduce scatter as you go. So, um,
we're going to step from left to right
here, and this is kind of going to be,
um, the entire sort of update process.
So, what you do is you're going to load
your model, you know, you have your two
GPUs at the top and the bottom. You're
first going to gather your weights for
this one layer, I'm going to forward
this one layer, and then I can free my
weights cuz I've already done before,
right? I don't need these parameters
anymore.
Now, let's say I only have one layer,
you know, um, now I can move to the
backwards process. Now, to do the
backwards step, I need the activations,
which I've kept, and I need the
parameters for this layer, which I can
all gather kind of on demand. I all
gather it, I do the backwards, and then
I scatter the gradients back right when
I get them, right? So, I got the
gradients, I reduce scatter the
gradients out, and then I free the
weights, I don't need them anymore, and
I repeat this process, right? So, I grab
the parameters as I need them, I compute
my backwards, I send the gradients out,
and I repeat this process, and then, you
know, I update my weights, all done,
right? Um,
so, what's the communication cost,
right? How many all gathers did we do?
We did two all gathers, one reduce
scatter. Um,
also, like, you know, so, we have one
extra all gather, which seems bad. It's
one thing. The second thing is this
seems a little crazy in terms of the
overhead because we're doing
communication all the time. Like, every
layer we're doing this communication.
Um, you might think that this is
extremely expensive and bad.
But, I think, you know, one of the
things that's counterintuitive and
important is, um,
you know, zero stage three uses kind of
two really important ideas to make this
essentially overhead free. Um, so, the
first one, which we've already seen, is
this idea that we're going to kind of
sweep through through compute graph, and
then we're going to do the necessary
communication, and then immediately free
the memory, right? That's already an
idea we've experienced. The other idea,
which I haven't talked about yet,
is we're going to overlap the
communication and computation cost of
this process, right?
And this is kind of hard to explain
initially, so I think I've I've taken
this plot from this
paper, which I think was explaining the
PyTorch FSDP sort of architecture.
So, the way that this kind of works is,
you know, in order so So, we have
different streams here. This is kind of
what's happening in the CPU. This is
what's happening in the GPU for
computation, and then what's happening
in the GPU for communication at the very
bottom here.
Now,
you know, the way FSDP works is I have
to first get my parameters before I can
do my computation. So, I'm going to all
gather zero layer zero, right? And once
I've all gathered, I can now do my
forward. But as I'm doing my forward,
notice that I'm requesting the next
layer's parameters. I'm all gathering
one while I'm doing this computation.
And now I all gathered one, I can now do
forward one, right? And I can start all
gathering two while I'm starting this
process. And so, I'm overlapping
computation and communication as I'm
kind of doing this. And you know, I
might spend some time freeing my
parameters. I might also spend some time
sort of computing another forward. For
example, if you reuse that W naught, you
know, I'm reusing this forward zero sort
of twice, right?
And so, what this allows you to do is if
you have enough computation and your
network's fast enough, by overlapping
communication and computation, right?
FSDP can basically be free, right? You
do see some bubbles. These are
overheads, but if your comms is very
fast and your computation is very big,
right? You can easily see how the
computation can run faster than the
communication, or say, the computation
can take longer than the communication,
and you end up having this really great
improvement in memory usage without
paying for almost any amount of memory
use.
Okay. So, um,
you know, when we look at the different
zero stages, right? Um, DDP, the naive
data parallel, costs two times
parameters, right? It was a single
all-reduce.
Um, the two zero stages, one and two,
right? The ones that shard gradient and
optimizer state, this is free in the
literal sense because it has the same
amount of comp uh, communication cost,
right? It's just the uh, identity of
all-reduce being equivalent to two
operations, right?
Um, now zero stage three is a little bit
more communications. You need an extra
all-gather, right? But, it's not so bad
because of the really clever ways in
which all these libraries can hide the
communication cost underneath the
computation. So, in practice, you know,
FSDP, if you run it, you're going to see
GPU utilization that's very close to,
you know, just the single GPU
performance. Like, it is actually quite
remarkable how good um, FSDP is. And
it's also very conceptually simple. You
will actually, um, have to write an FSDP
implementation as part of your
assignment. Um, and you know, you can
just kind of like write a wrapper that
will wrap any module and turn it into
its FSDP version, right? Um,
conceptually, all you're going to do is,
you know, do a bunch of all-gathers,
compute, free, and then repeat on the
backwards pass.
Okay, good.
Um, yes.
>> So, what I understand is that like we
are taking the
gradients from the next GPU to calculate
the gradients for the previous, right?
>> Um, when you say
>> Sequentially, like
>> So, so, we're not, um, I think what you
just described, which is like taking
gradients from one GPU to the next,
that's closer to pipelining. Pipelining
would be like if one layer was on one
GPU and another layer was on another
GPU. That's not the case. So, in all
these cases, you know, every, uh, GPU
kind of goes through the entire,
uh, model, right? From the start to
finish. Um, but the difference is no GPU
is going to hold the entire parameters
at the same time. And so, what we're
going to could is, you know, if I only
have part of the, you know, network that
doesn't have layer zero, I'm going to
sort of demand the layer zero parameters
first, and then do the full computation,
and then I'll move on to the next layer,
right? So, it's the same computation,
you know, it's the same single GPU
computation as naive data parallel, but
you can just kind of think of it as
request parameters, free parameters in
between every computational operation.
Yes.
>> So, are you saying that every GPU has a
part of every layer, and that's what the
optimizer is for?
>> Yes, that's all. So, so, the the picture
is here, right? Parameters gradients and
optimizer states are all sharded across
different GPUs. That's right.
Yeah.
Good. Oh, yes.
>> Why is the communication cost not
multiplied by the number of layers as
small?
>> Yeah, because these are So, so, the the
number of operations multiplies by
layer, that's So, that's correct. But,
each of these
these communication pieces is smaller,
right? Cuz this is just one tiny MLP or
something. Uh and I'm comparing that to
the the cost of all-reducing a whole
network, right? So, so, it all adds up
in some sense.
Yeah. Good.
Um
all right.
Okay, good. Um so, in practice, you
know, if you look at, you know, the
maximum size that can fit on, you know,
let's say a A100 GPU, um you know, if
you go from like the baseline, you can
not even fit a 7B model, and you go to
zero stage three, you know, you can now
fit, you know, 50 uh billion parameter
models and so on, right? So, um it
becomes a lot easier to fit these big
models using uh FSDP, right? The the
improvements that you get in terms of
the um
uh memory improvement is quite
significant.
Okay, yes.
>> So, can you go back to the previous
slide?
Uh so, regarding this uh on 8X E E100,
what would be uh what would be the
limitation on H100 or P200?
>> Okay, I I I can't do the mental math of
like multiply by 141 and divide by 80,
but it that would be the number for like
an H200,
um and so on and so forth. Yeah, it
would it would be linear, right? Like it
wouldn't really change the math very
much to to go from one accelerator to
another.
Um, okay. So, FSDP, I think is very
clean. It's very elegant. I like it a
lot.
Um, I wish I could end the lecture here,
but unfortunately, we will have to
proceed into uglier and more hairy
things. And there's, you know, two
reasons why we have to do that. One of
them, and this is an important idea for
parallelization, is that in some sense,
data parallel is consuming an important
resource. And that resource is kind of
the the batch size, so to speak, right?
If you have a batch size of eight, you
can never have more than a eight
accelerators, right? Um,
and you might think, okay, like let's
just make the batch size bigger and
bigger and bigger as we have more
accelerators. Um, you can't do that
because at a certain point, you know,
um, there's something called the
critical batch size where the basically
gain that you get from the additional
batch element is less than if you had
taken another SGD step on that single
element, right? So, there comes a point
where, you know, at at small batch
sizes, adding extra elements is, you
know, perfectly helpful. It's the same
as taking more SGD steps. But at a
certain point, diminishing return hits
in, and an infinitely large batch size
is not infinitely better than infinite
steps, right? Infinite single steps.
Um, because of this, now we have faced a
hard trade-off. Like, do we want small
batch sizes and let our GPUs be more
idle? Do we want big batch sizes and
sort of take the hit from optimization?
Sort of hard to say, right? There's
another issue that we have, which is
that we still have memory issues, which
is, um, you know, zero stages one and
two don't really let you scale memory at
all. And zero stage two lets you cut up
the parameter memory, um,
but unfortunately, you know, there's
activation memory and other kinds of,
you know, memory use that this does not
split up, or this does not reduce at
all, right? Um, and so we need better
ways, more fine-grained ways of cutting
up the model in order to really start
pushing down the memory use beyond these
points, right?
Um,
And so this kind of takes us to various
model parallelism ideas. Um and so model
parallelism is going to be this idea of
essentially like FSDP, we're going to
split up the parameters across GPUs. Um
but I think the important conceptual
difference between what we talked about
and what we will talk about next is that
now we are going to communicate
activations, right? In FSDP, we cut up
the parameters, but in some sense it was
just kind of a wrapper. We were still
doing the normal computation. We were
just sending parameters back and forth
before doing it, right? So parameters
were the things flying around. Now what
we're going to do instead is we're going
to communicate activations back and
forth, right? So if for example, one
layer lives on GPU zero, the next one
lives on GPU one, right? What I have to
communicate is the activation of the
layer in between, right? So that's going
to be um the big difference. And and
this will, you know, uh involve pipeline
parallel, which is cutting up layers, um
tensor parallel, which is cutting up
matrices, and expert parallel, which is
sharding experts into different places,
right? Um Percy's talked about, you
know, tensor parallel already, so you
have roughly some mental model of this.
Um I'll start by talking about pipeline
parallel um or layer-wise parallel. Um
you know, this is I think conceptually
very simple. Like, you know, back in the
the days when I first learned about
parallelism as like, "Oh yes, it's
simple. Just cut up the layers and put
them on different GPUs," right? Very
very simple thing. Um and so you're
going to pass activations uh forward in
the forward pass, and then you're going
to pass like partial gradients backwards
in the backward pass.
Now, okay, if I do this, what will
happen? You will get a terrible-looking
picture like this. Um very very
depressing. I have four um accelerators,
um each handling a quarter of the model.
And so what computation happens as a
function of time? So time is sweeping
from left to right, and the different
accelerators are the different rows.
So first, my uh zeroth accelerator at
the bottom here, that's handling the
first layer, will will do some
computation, and then it will stop,
right? And then it will hand off the
computation to the second one, and then
it will do nothing for the rest of time
um until the very end. And then I will
basically passing things back and forth,
and one GPU will be active at a time. Um
and then coming backwards, one GPU will
be active handling the backward pass at
a time. Um and so most of the time my
GPUs are idle. My utilization is truly
truly terrible.
Um and this is called a bubble. It's the
part of the pipeline where you're not
doing anything.
Um and the solution to this is to
essentially do kind of a batching or
pipelining. Um so instead of doing a
simple sort of one layer after another,
you're going to have a pipeline, right?
where in this case, in this picture
here, you have four elements to be
processed, and as soon as you process
one, you know, you start on the next
element, and then you pass off the the
one that's already done to your next
layer, right? So you can do this to
essentially pass elements upwards and
then back downwards. Um and so if you
want to to make this reasonable, then
what you need is, you know, the the
ratio of essentially this bubble time to
the useful compute the utilization in
some sense is going to be the number of
stages um divided by kind of this this
micro batches. And so we need a huge
batch size in order to to reduce this
bubble towards zero, right? Like so if
we want our bubble to be zero, it's
going to go down as one over the the
micro batch size.
This is kind of why I said um batch
sizes are useful resource because now we
can spend it in a different way, which
is the pipeline more to reduce the
amount of uh idle time in pipeline
parallel.
Okay. So pipelines are terrible. Um and
by folklore, you know, people say things
like, you know, parallelization code
looks reasonable and people can
understand it until you implement
pipeline parallel.
So why do we do pipeline parallel? Well,
you know, pipelines can save memory
compared to DDP cuz we've cut up layers,
and you You also compose this with data
parallel, so you can do both.
Um but the other reason why this is a
very important idea to learn um and you
will always have a pipeline in certain
kinds of topologies is that it has very
good communication properties um
compared to both FSDP and compared to
you know any other kinds of things you
can do. Um it only depends on
activations like B * S * H. It is also
point-to-point, you know, one layer is
going to communicate to another. It's
not all-to-all. And so, you know,
depending on how you sequence these
things, they can be a very efficient way
to utilize your network.
So, in practice, what we're going to do
is that pipelines are going to live on
the slowest networking links. So, if you
have, you know, multiple data centers or
multiple pods that are slower to talk
to, you're going to parallelize across
those two using pipeline parallel
because that's kind of the most
communication efficient uh parallelism
that you can kind of bring to bear uh
here.
Okay.
Um and as I said, you know, pipeline
performance is really dependent on batch
size. So, um I'll I'll point at this
paper repeatedly, but I'll mention which
one this is now. This is um uh the
Megatron paper from Nvidia. They have a
bunch of really lovely sort of parameter
sweeps of what happens to utilization as
a function of different sort of
configurations you can do.
Um so, as you if you have large batch
sizes and you pick a large pipeline
size, you can get pretty good
utilization close to, you know, not
doing pipeline parallel at all. Um but
you need the big batch sizes in order to
be able to to keep utilization up.
Otherwise, pipeline parallel is going to
rapidly degrade your utilization and
performance.
Actually, I'm going to pause for a
moment here to ask questions cuz the
next slide is uh is complicated. Yes.
>> So, you mentioned on the previous slide
that like pipelines have like good
communication properties compared to
FSDP. What is the specific mechanism for
why that is?
>> Um it's a smaller amount of stuff that's
being communicated. So, it's batch times
sort of sequence length times hidden.
And that's almost always a smaller
amount of data than like attempting to
communicate a whole parameter matrix,
right?
So, people have tried to figure out much
more clever ways
of, you know, reducing the amount of
pipeline sizes and you can kind of do
clever things that cut up sort of the
different stages of what you're doing
for different layers or different
microbatches. So, you can sequence
different forward pass elements in
between different backwards pass
elements and by doing sort of clever
scheduling, you can further reduce the
bubble size. This was taken from the
DeepSeek paper. So, by really cleverly
manipulating when you're doing forward
and backward computation, you can get a
little bit better in terms of the the
bubble size.
But, I think the even more clever thing
that you can do, uh which is called like
zero bubble pipelining,
um is not really about scheduling per
se, but it's actually about kind of
thinking carefully about the structure
of your backward pass. Um so, in the
backward pass, there's really two things
that have to happen. Um if you think
about it, you're kind of going backwards
in your computation graph and as you do
that, you're going to do two things. One
is going to be you're going to propagate
your sort of partial derivatives further
down your computation graph. So, like
remember, you know, back propagation,
you start at the end and you're
propagating these like partial
derivatives back, right? So, you have to
do that. But, you also want to compute
the gradients for the current weight,
right? So, you have two things that you
do at sort of every node of your
computation graph. You're going to
propagate backwards and you're going to
compute the derivative of your weight.
The important thing about, you know,
thinking about this compute graph is
actually, you know, one of these two is
really important for pipelines, like,
you know, and the other one you can kind
of do whenever.
Propagating the partials backwards,
right? That's very important because
your next stage can't do any work until
you've propagated that signal back. On
the other hand, the derivative with
respect to the weights, that is kind of
a leaf node, so to speak, on this graph,
and I can do it whenever, right? And so,
the clever thing to do now is you kind
of separate these two, right? Like so,
you got your B's over here. These B's
are kind of the backwards, right? We're
propagating backwards. And then, these
W's, these W's are computing the
derivative of the weights, and they can
happen whenever. So, what you do is you
compute the B's as quickly as you can,
right? So, those come first, and then
you can defer the W's until later and do
it when you have a gap in your
computation. And when you do this, you
can basically almost all completely fill
up the pipeline.
Um and this zero bubble pipelining thing
is very complicated, or much more
complicated than you would normally like
to deal with, but it allows you to
almost deal with these like pipelining
issues almost entirely, depending on,
you know, essentially the workload
involved in the W versus the B and so on
and so forth.
Good.
But I think, you know, having having
seen this, I was like, "Oh, this is this
is so clever. Such clever things that
you can do um with systems."
Okay.
So, that was pipelining. Um
any questions about that?
Good.
So, I think there's a natural sort of
uh analogy, or like a parallel you can
think of. So, pipeline parallel is like
depth. So, you have your depth, you cut
up your your network along the depth
dimension.
Um but we have two ways that we scale,
right? We got a depth axis, and we have
a width axis. So, how What if we start
cutting up our model along width, right?
So, this is uh tensor parallel, as Percy
explained before. Um and it's really the
simple idea that, you know, matrix
multiplies can kind of be cut up into
smaller matrix multiplies, which you
then add the partial sums back together.
This is the really the same idea as
tiling, as well. So, this core primitive
just appears many, many times.
Um
And so, when you do this in practice,
right? What does this actually look
like? Um so, this is a, you know, GELU
that's happening. So, what do you
normally do? You have your X coming in
as input on the on the very uh right of
this slide here. Um and then I have a
matrix A that I multiply with. I apply
my non-linearity GELU, and then I
multiply with B to down project, and
then I output my Z, right? This is the
normal sort of serial computation that I
do. Now, in tensor parallel, what I
would do is I would cut up my A into two
sub-matrices, my B into two
sub-matrices, and then I would, you
know, run the computations in parallel,
and I would sort of gather them together
at the end.
Now, one thing that is, you know, kind
of important is there's kind of a
duality between the forward and backward
pass. So, in the forward pass, you know,
all I do with the X's I, you know, copy
them twice, and then I run the
computation forward. So, F is the
identity, this F function.
And then once I get to the end of my
parallel component, the G function,
that's a all reduce that brings them
back together, right? But in the
backwards pass, as I'm doing my
gradients, this is going to flip. My G
is going to be an all uh sorry, my G is
going to be an identity, right? Because
the partial derivatives are coming
backwards. And then my F are the
partials, you know, that I need to sum
up in order to get my, you know, partial
derivatives at the start of this module,
right? So, they're going to flip and and
and this duality is kind of important if
you're going to, you know, write tensor
parallel.
Okay. Um and so, you know, you you might
have already noticed, right? But when we
split things, you know, some of the the
ways that we cut are going to be
column-wise. So, column-wise uh tensor
parallel is going to happen at the kind
of the inputs, right? So, the inputs of
the MLP, the projections of the
attention, are going to be cut up by the
columns um in uh each transformer block.
So, this is column-wise uh cuts. And
then there's going to be row-wise cuts
in sort of the corresponding second
stage. So, in the uh down projections of
the MLP, um as well as the outputs of
the attention, you're going to have a
row-wise cut. And then everything that's
kind of a small layer, like a layer norm
or like a non-linearity or routers in ML
uh sorry, in MOEs, those are all fully
replicated across the machines. You
don't really want to bother with the the
overhead of uh cutting those guys.
Okay. And then like so, when do we do
tensor parallel?
Um tensor parallel is extremely uh
computation hungry. Um
what you're doing is every time you have
a matmul, you're going to be doing some
communication, right? You have a all
reduce or you have a you know, in the
backwards pass you have a you have a all
reduce here. Um one in the in the G when
you you're going forward. Um and these
are kind of activation size and you're
doing them very frequently.
So, this is very communication hungry
and so you only want to do this um
within a uh node. So, for GPUs, um you
know, eight GPUs are going to be
networked tightly together in a single
box. And so, up to eight, you might be
willing to do some tensor parallel. Once
you go beyond that, you're going to be
going cross-node and those uh
interconnects, those connections, are
much slower and so you're going to get a
big drop in performance as soon as you
sort of hit that point of going beyond a
single machine. So, tensor parallel you
should kind of remember as very
communication hungry. You usually use it
in the fastest interconnects that you
have at hand.
Um
and this is kind of the point at which I
you know, I'm going to sort of go back
to the thing I said about TPUs, right?
Remember for TPUs, you don't really have
this distinction between fast eight GPUs
and and next machines. You just have
this big mesh. Um and so, one of the big
advantages that TPU people will tell you
is, you know, you can tensor parallel
very large numbers compared to the GPU
world because they're able to sort of
have high bandwidth in this very regular
communication uh pattern um over this
mesh, right? So, that's a big difference
if you're parallelizing between TPUs
versus GPUs, the amount of tensor
parallelism you use versus pipeline
parallel will actually be quite
different.
Okay.
So, how do we compare these two? They're
both model splitting strategies. They'll
both save on, you know, both uh
parameters and potentially activations.
Um the pros here of of tensor parallel
is that there's no necessarily pipeline
bubble. Um and if your network's fast
enough, you know, you might be able to
get full utilization.
Um it's also low complexity. It's just
cutting up some matmuls. Um
but the con is that the communication is
much larger. It used to be that you were
doing B * S * H point-to-point
communication. Now instead, I'm going to
be doing something like 8 * B * S * H uh
times roughly one uh all-reduce
communication, right? So this is not
even just point-to-point. This is, you
know, all-to-all communication that
needs to happen.
So tensor parallel is great whenever we
have high-speed interconnects. Every
other time we probably want to be using
pipeline parallel.
Okay.
So the last thing I want to talk about
about sort of, you know, we're talking
about memory use, um is to, you know,
really think
care more carefully about memory. I
think the most naive view of memory in
kind of deep learning and language
modeling is something like, well, memory
is just parameters. Like that's this
green bit over here, right? You have a
certain number of bits you need to store
for your parameters. You know, that's
it. Um
I've already talked about optimizer
state, which is important, which is this
yellow box over here. Um but if you look
at this plot, this is, you know, actual
memory use as profiled in one of the
PyTorch profilers, um you'll find
actually that this is not really the
whole story. There's a lot of dynamic
memory that needs to exist in um in a
computation. You need to store all the
activations. These are these big red
bumps over here. And then as you compute
your gradients, you kind of need to
store them in your backward sweep,
right? And so really maximum memory
usage happens a little bit after, you
know, the maximum activation point. Like
after you start sweeping backwards on
your gradient, but you still need to
compute a lot of keep your activations,
those are usually the maximum memory
points, right? So to reduce this, maybe
we need to deal with this big red hump,
this activation.
Um
And if you start looking at um sort of
more modern um
sort of workloads for language models,
um you start to find that as you get to
sort of bigger and bigger parameters.
Forget the column that says present
work, I'll talk about that in a moment
here. But, if you look at just the
baseline columns of this plot, as you go
to bigger models for moderately large
sequence lengths, you know, your
activations are just kind of going to
dwarf the parameter memory that you
need. And so, any sort of memory saving
strategy has to sort of reason about
activations in order to be fully
effective. Like, we can't just deal with
um parameter memory. That's not really
sufficient uh for us.
So, if we're storing everything, and
this is kind of a good, I don't know, uh
statistic or rule of thumb to start
with, um if we need to store everything,
the amount of activations that we need
um is going to be something like 34 * S
* B * H. And that's going to be sequence
length * batch size * hidden dimension
size plus 5 * AS / H. So, that's AS is
attention heads * sequence length /
hidden dimension size. And this SBH
dependence, right, is kind of
fundamental um because, you know, we
expect to have to store something for
every element of the sequence. We expect
to have to store something for every
batch element. And we expect to have to
store something for every hidden dim
size, right? So, we're going to see this
SBH term uh repeatedly as we try to go
through different ways of reducing
activation memory and accounting for the
total amount of activation memory. Um
and in case you're curious where the
terms come from, um you know, this
odd-looking term, the 5 AS / H, is going
to come from the quadratic attention
terms including the dropout terms. Um
and we can drop this term via
recomputation if we do flash attention.
Um
Okay.
Now, what if we did tensor parallel?
Like, you know, one of the promises that
I made to you in talking about model
parallelism was that we could reduce
activation
quite a bit. So, now let's think about
what happens. Well, tensor parallel is
going to split out the matrix multiplies
in attention and MLPs. So, which parts
are those? Well, the MLPs are 24
of those those those 34 that I talked
about before
and the attention heads are 5 AS over
HT, right? The second term over here.
Now, I can reduce that by T, my tensor
parallel size, and that's kind of good.
This is not bad because I've taken you
know, most of the memory and I've made
it scale linearly with the tensor
parallel size T. So, that's good.
But, it turns out that there are other
things that you do. Like, you might have
a layer norm. You might have a dropout.
You need to keep the inputs to attention
and the MLP, right? Cuz the the inputs
to each layers need to be stored as
residuals for the for the backwards
pass.
And unfortunately, these are not reduced
with your tensor parallel size, right?
Tensor parallel does not split the layer
norm and therefore it does not split the
activation for these guys, right? So,
this is unfortunate because you were
hoping that if you had a thousand
different GPUs in tensor parallel cuz
you're Google, you might be able to
reduce this activation dramatically. The
unfortunate reality is that you're still
going to suffer a 10x SBH penalty for
doing all of this.
And so, the last part that's usually
used in composition with tensor parallel
is this idea of sequence parallel. This
is an extremely misleading name because
usually when I say sequence parallel,
actually there's a thing called context
parallel that is actually more natural
for this name, but sequence parallel is
kind of the the following idea. So, what
you're going to do is we have these
remaining terms, 10 SBH, and these terms
are very lightweight. They're like layer
norms. They're stuff that doesn't have
much computation.
And what I'm going to do is I'm going to
split them up somehow. And I'm going to
split them up over the sequence axis
rather than over the hidden axis.
And this is going to then involve all
gathers and reduce scatters
before every operation where we need
these.
And if you think about it, this is very
reminiscent of FSDP, right? We have this
thing that we need. We need attention We
need activations at some point. We need
to compute the activations going forward
and we need the activations when we
sweep backwards for the derivatives,
right? But we don't need them now. So
we're going to store them by sort of
split them up splitting them up across
the sequence axis and materializing them
on demand. So I would say this is like
conceptually very similar to the FSDP
style idea
where we're kind of storing them in this
sharded format and then we're gathering
them as we need them.
And then as I said before, there's a
duality to this. So in the forward pass,
you know, G is an all gather, G bar is a
reduced scatter. In the backwards pass,
this is going to be reversed, right? The
the all gather and reduce scatter are
going to be reversed
between G and G bar.
So if I do this now, what do I get?
Well, remember with the no parallelism
setting, the very first part, you know,
what I told you was you get this
activation memory. You use 34 times SBH
with an attention head component.
With tensor parallel, you know, I get to
divide the MLP part and the the
attention part by T, but not all these
other sort of point wise ops that I
have.
If I do sequence parallel, I've split
these up by my accelerators as well just
in the sequence axis, which gives me now
fully linear dependence.
If I do activation recomputation, I can
even drop the second term because
remember this is just the the storage
that I need for the softmax. So I can
drop this through recomputation, which
gives you SBH times 34 over T.
This This nice to remember because this
is kind of the lower bound of what you
can achieve reasonably speaking
for normal training for activation
memory. And so if you want to do things
like compute by hand whether your model
will fit into a GPU, this is a good
thing to remember. You need at least
this much for activation memory. You're
going to need some memory for your
optimizer state and you will need some
memory for your parameters and your
gradient. And once you have those
things, you have a rough
sense of how much memory you're going to
need for your model.
Okay, I'm going to stop here for a
moment. I have talked through both
pipeline and tensor parallel at this
point. And so people might be a little
bit confused and we can talk through a
few things before I move on to expert
parallel.
Good.
Oh, yes.
24 over key is MLP part of this.
MLP part cannot be
optimized through the recomputation.
You can recompute the MLP as well. Like
you can do a lot more recomputation than
what is listed here.
But recomputation beyond what is listed
here is very computationally expensive.
Like your recomputation for MLP involves
running the MLP again in the backward
pass, which you probably do not want to
do.
Recomputation for attention is generally
cheaper, yeah. Because you do it tile
wise as well. Yeah, and and also you
don't want to pay the quadratic cost.
That's quite expensive. The quadratic
cost.
Okay.
Cool. All right.
So I'm going to talk now talk about the
last
ingredient in sort of the standard
parallelism toolbox, which is expert
parallelism, right? Now that MOEs are
very standard part of a toolkit, you
know, most big models are MOEs these
days and that allows us to take
advantage of one of their big benefits,
which is expert parallelism.
Um and expert parallelism, you know, I
think of myself as
um being something analogous to tensor
parallel, right? In the sense that
you're taking the MLPs, right? The the
FFN components of your network, and
you're going to split them up in various
ways, and you'll incur a communication
penalty. It's in the same way that
you're maybe splitting up the matrices,
except here you're splitting up the
whole MLP across different devices.
Um and the systems behavior of tensor
parallel is uh oh sorry, expert parallel
is roughly like tensor parallel as well.
In the sense that this is a high
bandwidth parallelism primitive that
also reduces activation. Um but one
important thing is that if you're doing
a ML uh MoE, um you almost always prefer
uh using an expert parallel sharding
strategy over tensor parallel. I've
taken this screenshot from um the
parallelism guidelines from
uh Megatron, which is Nvidia's like
parallelism library. It's a really
wonderful uh library and document. Um
and one of the guidelines they say is,
"Look, if you're going to do some sort
of parallelism, either EP or TP, you
know, you should be using EP over TP."
Why is that?
Well, this is actually a good list of
drawbacks for a tensor parallel. If you
have a matrix, and then you cut up the
matrix too finely, well, the matrices
are going to start to get small, and
your GPU utilization will suffer, right?
So, you want your mat matmuls as big as
possible, and tensor parallel kind of
reduces that. Um for MoE layers, it's a
lot easier to sort of route sparse token
activations, rather than to sort of
potentially route these dense big tensor
parallel matmul activations.
Um and then, um
you know,
you can sort of do things like um
uh route tokens exactly to the places
that they need, and you can sort of skip
some computation or sorry, some overhead
uh in the cases that if you're going to
have uh MoE anyway, you might as well
have the number of experts sort of split
up over all the devices.
Um
Now, this Sorry. Yeah, okay.
This might make it seem like, all right,
EP is great. Everyone should be doing
expert parallel all the time. Um
unfortunately, expert parallel is still
really complicated and still very
difficult. I think everything that I've
said after FSDP, you know, tensor
parallel, pipeline parallel,
systems-wise is quite non-trivial to get
working really well. Um and I'll just
point to two different libraries, not to
tell you the details of what happens
inside of them, but to tell you this is
like kind of seriously complicated
business.
Deep Seek has a library called DPP,
which I think is is one of my favorite
things from the Deep Seek V3 era, which,
you know, is basically their own library
for doing expert parallel sort of
routing and dispatching, where they're
like looking at really low-level uh GPU
networking primitives in order to try
to, you know, basically combine
different operations or like have the
hardware handle certain operations in
order to make MOE routing as sort of
efficient as possible.
Similarly, NVIDIA has a library called
Hybrid EP, which, you know, is a
similar, you know, effort of having very
efficient low-level hardware
implementations of um expert parallel
dispatching. Um and just to like give
you the high-level thing, right? Um the
reason why this stuff is hard is, you
know, you are doing a lot of all-to-all
dispatches. If you look at the
communications pattern of of a MOE, much
like tensor parallel, every time you
have a MLP, you're going to have to
route tokens all sorts of different
places, um and you need to do this in a
very latency-sensitive way because your
computation is waiting for your tokens
to arrive. So, reducing sort of the
latency of this dispatch is extremely
extremely important.
And sort of one final thing that is like
a fun trivia about the DPP library is,
you know, the the Deep Seek folks are so
intense that you know in order to
optimize like every last bit of
performance they basically looked and
found sort of undocumented
um sort of PTX which is like you know
GPU machine code um or machine code like
things um and they found how to use
these undocumented instructions to
further accelerate their networking
communication. So really this is like
the level of stuff that you kind of need
in order to get to the frontier of you
know parallelism and efficiency.
Um finally you know up until now I've
sort of talked about all the parallelism
primitives in isolation like data
parallel and so on and so forth um with
the implicit assumption that you can
just kind of like put them together like
LEGO blocks. And this is true for the
most part for basically all the other
parallelism strategies like it's very
easy to combine like I don't know data
and tensor parallel.
Um expert parallel um has sort of
additional constraints that you want to
be somewhat respectful of. Usually um
the naive way to do data and expert
parallelism which I think is in many of
the old libraries is that the sort of
replicas for for DP and EP are the same.
So in other words like let's say I have
a data parallelism of eight you know I'm
going to shard my eight experts uh my
experts across those eight replicas and
then my data will be split across those
eight replicas and routed in various
ways right? So in other words you split
your GPUs according to DP and then your
EP is sort of a subset of that split
right? And this is a a very natural
thing to do because you're routing
tokens. Um but if you do this um there's
a maximum bound to how far you can
parallelize with EP and it constrains
sort of how uh DP and TP interact.
Um and so I think this is the final
complexity. I apologize that expert
parallel is a little bit you know like
really messy in many ways um but because
of these complexities um there is
actually this one interesting sort of
systems thing that I'll I'll tell you
about before I I stop talking about EP,
um which is this following fact.
Remember, MOEs only change the MLPs,
right? They don't change the attention
at all, right? So, um because we're
cutting up the MLPs, but not the
attention, this means that expert
parallelism kind of applies unevenly to
the model. So, when I parallelize at the
expert level, I'm parallelizing the
MLPs, but I'm not parallelizing the
attention, right? Um and so, in order to
parallelize the attention, you know,
maybe I want to also use tensor
parallel, right? So, I want a high
tensor parallel level in order to cut up
my attention, um but, you know, this is
going to then affect uh my my
uh my MLPs, because if I have high
tensor parallel and high expert
parallel, I've cut up my matri- matrices
into really tiny pieces, and my
utilization is very bad. So, there's
this weird trade-off where you want high
tensor parallel for the attention, but
you want low tensor parallel for the
MLPs. So, you know, there's this
conflict.
Um so, what do you do? Well, um in the
last few years, people have come up with
more complicated system solutions that
kind of decouple the tensor parallel uh
in the MLPs and the attention. And so,
the attention layers get one kind of
tensor parallel, and the MOE layers get
another kind of tensor parallel, um and
so, now you can fully decouple the
parallelism, um and this leads to, you
know, more complicated, but more
effective combinations of of EP and uh
tensor parallel, as well as as uh data
parallel.
Cool.
Okay.
So, the last thing uh in this space that
I kind of want to end with, um is uh
context parallel. So, context parallel,
or uh ring attention, um is an idea of
basically splitting activations in a
very long sequence across different
accelerators. Um and you can do things
like, you know, pass the uh
to the uh sort of device that's needed
in kind of this ring-like way following
the mesh topology uh of TPUs.
And so, ring attention, which I think
was the original paper that did this, um
showed that this worked really well on
TPUs. Um context parallel is a standard
parallelization strategy that does this.
Both of these are used in long context
extension stages and in uh sort of model
serving. Um I'm not going to talk about
it um mainly because I think it overlaps
in concept to a lot of what we've talked
about already.
Okay.
Um so, this is the end of the second
part, and I think to to put everything
together, I've made a big table of um
parallelization strategies, including
data parallel, which are the top two
rows, and the various model parallelism
strategies below them. Um
and I think, you know, I've colored in
red what I subjectively feel like are
the drawbacks of the different methods.
Um and the reason why I've colored
things in red is to try to convey to you
that there is no one strictly dominant
parallelization strategies. It's all
like a whole bunch of trade-offs that
you somehow have to manage gracefully in
order to get a good outcome. So, you
know, for example, FSDP is great. It's a
wonderful strategy, does not help you
with activation, it sort of consumes
your global batch size in order to to do
parallelization, right? So, it has
limits. And to address these, you know,
maybe you want to compose them with some
of these other tricks that you have at
hand. You know, maybe you want to do
some tensor parallel to cut down on
activation memory. Um it also doesn't uh
touch global batch size, but if you do
this, now you need fast networking, and
you need um sort of high bandwidth,
and also then to to leverage your slower
connections, maybe you want to use some
of the other parallelization strategies,
right? So, you kind of see how all these
different advantages means that there's
a place for one of these parallelization
strategies in, you know, not every
architecture, but in many large-scale
architectures use a large combination of
these. Yes.
>> And if you take pipeline and FSDP, are
they still applicable to MOEs, or is
that strictly any thing
>> Yeah, so um the question was, you know,
is pipeline and and uh what, FSDP
applicable to MOEs? Yes, yes, they're
absolutely applicable.
Um if anything, like the standard
recommendation um is, you know, expert
parallel is kind of like tensor
parallel, so you want to go up to like
eight or like, you know, eight fast
connections.
Um people don't really follow that
anymore. Um but even then, FSDP and or
data parallel in general, and pipeline
and tensor are used extensively in all
the frontier models. Yeah.
Good. Okay. Uh and you will do this uh
or something like this as part of your
assignment, but one of the things that's
cool about parallelism, and I think is
nice, is that you can do some math,
right? You can actually say, okay, how
much compute do I do per layer for my
different sharding strategies? How much
communication do I do per layer for my
different communication strategies? And
if I have different devices allocated to
different communication strategies, how
do these things scale? And then I can
figure out, you know, for a combination
of these strategies, you know, how do
they scale? And you can start to sort of
make plots of, you know, if I have a
certain batch size, and I have a certain
parallelization strategy, so I have
three different parallelization
strategies here, you know, how much am I
sort of utilizing my GPU? Right, the
ratio of compute time to communications
time. And as long as my compute time is
longer than communications time, in
principle, you know, you can just hide
communications underneath your
computation, right? Um and so you can
make plots like this, where, you know,
this dash line at the very top, that's
kind of the the boundary of where you're
efficient. Anything above that is sort
of fully utilizing your computation.
Anything below that is on the on the bad
part of your roof line, right? You're
waiting for communication to do your
computation.
And one thing that's pretty interesting
here, right? So, I think this should
feel intuitive to you based on what I've
told you. If your batch size is big
enough, FSDP only is good, right? Like
if you have a batch size of 2,000,
right? Um per chip. Um So, then, you
know, how how far can you go? Well,
you've got FSDP doing extremely well.
You're fully compute bound, right? But,
the important thing is as the batch size
goes down, FSDP only will hit a point
where you're now communication bound.
Now, what do you do, right? Well, what
do you do is now, in order to keep
pushing efficiencies, you have to
incorporate MP, in this case is tensor
parallel, to the mix, right? Now, you
can sort of push that curve out a little
bit more and be compute bound even into
smaller batch size regimes, right? And
and you keep adding strategies to push
this curve out in order to get something
better.
And this is, you know, what people call
3D or 4D. I don't think there's 5D. Uh
parallelism, which is when you put all
these strategies together to keep your
uh compute units fully utilized um under
different communication topologies.
There's a very simple prescription. Um
you know, I think up until now I've been
telling you things in generalities, so
it might feel complicated. But, I think
actually the the strategy for how you
parallelize is very simple, actually.
Which is until your model fits into
memory, you're going to cut up your
model by whatever means necessary,
right? And how are you going to cut up
your model? You're going to use either
tensor or expert parallel for your fast
interconnect. And so, if you have eight
GPUs per machine, you're going to use a
a tensor or expert parallel of eight.
And then, you're going to pipeline
parallel or zero three, you know, which
is FSDP, um the rest of the way to make
your model fit. And once your model
fits, then you're going to just data
parallel the rest of the way, right?
They used up the rest of your GPUs with
data parallel, right? Um if your batch
size ends up being too small, you can do
gradient accumulation uh to get better
GPU utilization, right?
Very simple strategy.
And this is born out in, you know, the
actual kind of like large-scale parallel
training libraries that you might use.
So, I've added the link here to to
Megatron's like guide to sort of
paralyzing MOEs.
But this idea actually applies to the
dense models as well. And you see
exactly the thing that I said, but kind
of in reverse order. So, guideline
number one is minimize model
parallelism, maximize data parallelism,
right? so use most of your GPUs to shard
data if you can. Now, if you're using
GPUs, you know, stay within NVLink. So,
that's one machine or so one one box,
right? Keep expert parallel and tensor
parallel within one box, right? And then
if you're going to go multi-node, use
pipeline parallelism to go multi-node.
And then, you know, if you're MOE, then
prefer expert parallel. And then
finally, if you're doing long sequences,
use context parallel, right? Ring
attention.
So, exactly kind of what I've been
trying to get across to you through the
lecture,
but you know, in kind of practitioner
form that you see here.
Okay.
The final component, actually maybe I
can pause here in case anyone's curious
about like 4D parallelization stuff.
Yeah.
Oh, yeah, yeah.
Well, I mean sequence parallel is like
often just like you know, you do it with
tensor parallel in order to reduce
activations. It's kind of more like an
add-on that you you put in in order to
reduce activation. It's not its own like
standalone thing in many cases.
Yeah.
>> With the suspicions that that those is
like a loop transformer or something
like that,
is
does that make things easier or harder?
>> Okay.
I don't know how much I I buy the loop
transformer mythos rumors. Maybe it is,
it'll be interesting.
Okay, but to the question of like what
how the system's structured is would
change.
It's a good question. I mean I guess
it might mess with things like FSDP.
Like you can't really discard the
weights. It does have the advantage
though that like you don't have to keep
getting weights. Like it is much more
parameter efficient and so much maybe
much of the model parallelism stuff
wouldn't be as important. Um it it would
be interesting. It would be definitely
different um
for a lot of the FSDP style things cuz
the FSDP strategy is really predicated
on like get weights, discard weights,
get weights, discard weights and in a
loop you're not discarding anything.
Good. Okay.
All right. So um this is an old paper
but it is actually a you know probably
one of the best resources um
and also it's not like the the
networking fundamentals changed that
much. So I think you know the the
lessons from here are very relevant
today.
Um and so this is a paper by Nvidia and
formerly unfortunately Stanford folks uh
Matei and Deepak um who did a bunch of
runs of large-scale parallel training
across many different configurations to
basically tell you you know as you're
scaling up how should your
parallelization strategies change across
um different uh scales. Um and you see
exactly this prescription that I've been
talking about before which is you know
you have data parallel um sort of maxed
out and then your tensor parallel kind
of increases until it hits eight and
then you stop because you don't want to
go any higher and then from that point
on your pipeline parallel increases and
increases and increases. Right? Um and
with sufficiently large scale um data
parallel kind of decreases and at the
very end you have a DP of six and this
is because you just need this much
tensor and pipeline parallel to fit the
stuff right and you're using the rest of
your budget on data parallel.
Um and if you sort of put them all
together right even as you you know go
to you know ludicrously large numbers of
GPUs you know your utilization stays
very flat and very good. And this is why
I think, you know, you see these
gigantic data center build outs. Like
the parallelization strategies people
have come up with are kind of so
effective and the hardware for
communication is so good that even with
the gigantic data centers or even cross
data center training, um you can get
really good utilization um across, you
know, these different uh regimes.
Um they have really nice quantitative
evidence showing you, you know, for
different batch sizes, for tensor
parallel, you know, what is the right
place to stop and it's clearly, you
know, um
tensor parallel size of eight. As you
go, you know, beyond that, you're going
to get into trouble. Um in pipeline
parallel, you also need big batch sizes
in order to be able to to utilize uh the
machines effectively. That's kind of why
there's a blue to orange gap. There's
pipeline parallel and the larger the
pipeline parallel, you know, the larger
the gap between orange and blue.
Um and then I think another thing that
maybe you have already internalized from
flash attention, but maybe not, is, you
know, maybe you should do a bunch of
activation recomputation because if you
do activation recomputation, you know,
very cleverly, then you can get a bigger
batch size and the bigger batch size
then allows you to get better
utilization. Um this is kind of a
initially I think very counterintuitive
observation that actually you should do
more computation via recomputation in
order to, you know, end up getting
better utilization because it allows you
to save memory and memory can be turned
into batch size.
Okay.
So that was um kind of a more
quantitative view of how to pick
parallelism strategies.
Um the last thing I want to end with is
just to look at just a very few um
training runs and looking at the
training runs, maybe we can get a sense
of how modern parallelization is used in
practice and how it's evolving.
So Dolma um by AI2 was a 7B open source
model.
Um
uh sorry, Olmo, which was trained on the
Dolma data set. And this is in the Dolma
paper for the details. Um,
was a 7B model, uh, trained fully with
FSDP across, um, a whole bunch of
accelerators. I forget exactly how many.
Um,
but, you know, this is one example of,
you know, FSDP scales surprisingly well,
even to like many, many GPUs, as long as
you're training a small model, you know,
FSDP is actually a pretty good strategy
for parallelization. I think many 7B-ish
models are trained purely with FSDP.
Um, DeepSeek, because of their systems,
you know, skills, does do some pretty
exotic and and useful stuff. Um, so
DeepSeek V1, uh, was trained just with
data parallel zero stage one, um, with
tensor sequence and pipeline parallel,
as I kind of talked you before.
DeepSeek V3, you know, that's a MoE
model, if you remember my MoE lecture.
So, they have, you know, not only
pipeline parallel, but they also have
expert parallel, instead of tensor
parallel, right? And their expert
parallel actually is a little bit
exotic, because they have 64-way
parallelism. So, they group eight
different machines together, and that's
their expert parallel sort of domain.
Um, and to to enable this large expert
parallel, they basically use the same
tricks that they have, um, from their
uh, pipeline parallel pipelining, in
order to try to make sure that expert
parallel doesn't sort of like have, uh,
low utilization periods. So, this is
actually a quite a complicated trick
that they do to get these very large
expert parallel splits.
Um,
another example, Yi, from, uh, Chinese
open weights training, uh, setting, they
use, once again, zero stage one and
tensor and pipeline parallel, right?
This very much makes sense. It's a it's
the classic data parallel, tensor
parallel, pipeline parallel combo.
Um, and once again, once you go to, uh,
MoEs, you replace the tensor parallelism
with expert parallelism, right? They
they serve similar sort of goals, um,
but expert parallelism is just a little
bit more efficient.
Um, it on the other extreme of a really
big dense model, you have Llama 3. Um,
the Llama 3 report I like quite a bit,
um, because they're one of the few
reports that have like literally a full
breakdown of their parallelism strategy,
not just like in the abstract, but
across all the different phases. So, um,
the cool thing that you see is they
have, um, a pre-pre-training stage, like
a little warm-up phase at the very
start. You can ignore that first row.
And then you have their main sort of
pre-training phase in the middle row
here. Um, and this is a very standard
parallelization strategy. Tensor
parallel of eight, um, one sort of
context parallel, 16 pipeline parallel,
and 128 data parallel, right? Like big
data parallel, uh, splits. And then at
the very end, because they want a long
context model, they do long context
extension. And for this, they crank up
the context parallel, lower the data
parallel, and that's kind of how they
parallelize this very memory-hungry
stage for long context extension. Um,
and notice, you know, we're in tensor
parallel, not expert parallel land,
because Llama 3 405B is a gigantic dense
model. It's not a a MoE model.
Um,
and as a side note, right? Like one
thing that I don't talk about, but if
you, for example, become an infra
engineer at one of these companies, um,
you'll notice is, you know, GPUs fail
all the time. Um, apparently in during,
uh, Llama 3 405B training, um, GPUs
failed 148 times. And so, you need, you
know, lots of not just like fast
parallelism, you need redundancy in
order to be able to deal with all these
like kind of horrible things that can
happen to your training. So, there's a
distributed systems challenge as well.
Um,
Gemma 2, which is a uh
Google open source model, um, has, uh,
FSDP plus tensor parallel and sequence
parallel, um,
and uses these two strategies only. And
the reason why I sort of brought up
Gemma 2 is, as far as as this is
basically, uh, a realization of the
Google claim that, you know, for TPUs,
really you don't need to do pipelines,
you just take a really big toroidal
mesh, and you do tensor tensor parallel
over that big mesh network that you
have.
Unclear whether this can like scale out
forever. Um that has always been a
little bit
uh less clear to me, but at least at,
you know, the Gemma scales, this is
definitely the case.
Finally, um I took a look at some of the
models that were trained this year, like
Mixtral 8x22B. Um and during my
investigation, you know, one of the
things that I discovered was actually,
you know, if you're interested in like
model training and parallelism
configurations in the wild, um
Nvidia has a repository called uh
Megatron Bridge, where they sort of
release a lot of, you know, recommended
training configurations for a lot of
different model sizes and model
settings. Um and you can kind of take a
look at what they end up saying is the
right model configuration for like a
8x24 22B uh MoE or DeepSeek v3 model.
And so, for Mixtral, you know, they do
expert parallel of eight, pipeline
parallel four, and an additional tensor
parallel of four. This one for the
attention layers. And you kind of see,
you know, this follows the prescription
of keep your expert parallel roughly
around eight.
Um
NeMo Tron 3 Super um follows kind of the
DeepSeek v3 model, has a bunch of expert
parallel, as well as context parallel,
because they were doing extensions, uh
at least in this article.
Um and then the last one that I want to
talk about is Qwen 3, um which follows
the DeepSeek recipe, which is uh fairly
large amount of expert parallel, 32, um
and they have uh eight pipeline parallel
and two tensor parallel to split up kind
of things like the attention matrices.
Um
It is actually kind of interesting to
see um additionally the the different
kinds of benchmarking that Nvidia folks
have done for, you know, parallelizing
different models. And you see, um I
won't go into details of what this is.
This is in the um Nvidia Bridge repo, if
you want to take a look.
There's all sorts of different like sub
configurations that you can pick even
within tensor parallel that can
significantly affect the performance of
these. So, the the systems integration
is quite significant.
So, to sort of put everything together,
you know, I kind of decided maybe I
would build overview.
Really the thing that's common to this
is, you know, as much as you can, all
the models use data parallel. They
maximize the data parallel domains to
the extent that they can.
Tensor parallel almost always remains
below eight.
And expert parallel can sometimes be big
now, and I think that's partially
because of Deep Seek V3 and a lot of the
infra that they built for large-scale
expert parallel training.
Good.
Okay.
So, to put everything together, right?
The highest-level point, right, of this
lecture is we need to think about
multi-GPU, multi-node, maybe even
multi-data center parallelism. And to
think about efficiency in that regime,
right? We need to really bring to bear
all the approaches that we have because
you've got fast links, you've got slow
links, you've got
techniques that make use of batch sizes
and all these different resources that
you all want to consume as much as
possible.
But, given all these, it turns out that
there's fairly simple rules of thumb for
combining all these different forms of
parallelism to get, you know, in the end
what is effective,
effectively like full utilization of
your computer hardware.
And next week I think we're talking
about scaling loss.